مهمه العسكريه الروتينيه انتهت بخساره
اوكرانيا الثلاثه من ابرز مسؤوليها وهم في
طريقهم لبقعه ساخنه من القتال
مدينه بروفاريه الاوكرانيه اصبحت شاهده
على اللحظات الاخيره لاولئك المسؤولين هم
وزير الداخليه دينيس مونستر
الدوله في وزاره الشؤون الداخليه
لجهاز الدوله حادثه الواقعه بالقرب من
العاصمه كيف في مدينه بروفاريه على بعد 20
كيلومترا شمال شرق العاصمه تسببت الحادثه
في سقوط 10 القتل والمصابين بينهم اطفال
متاثرين باصدام المروحيه بمبدا سكني
وحضاره رسميا لا تزال السلطات الاوكرانيه
تعمل على معرفه ملابسات الحادثه وتجمع
الادله فيما اعلنت المانيا استعدادها
للمشاركه في التحقيق للوقوف على ما اذا
كان الحادث مدبرا لانه بسبب عطل فني او
بسبب الطقس
الجزيره بالذكر ان عمليه نقل المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين تتم اعاده بطائره مروحيه تحلق
على مستوى منخفض جدا ما قد ينطوي على
مخاطر عده وفاته وزير الداخليه الاوكراني
التي تاتي وسط تصعد الحرب بين اوكرانيا
وروسيا قد تؤثر على عمل الحكومه مع
خسارتها وزير المختصه في مهام حيويه بينها
اداره الشرطه خلال الحرب